what up space fam goes in here for anime
up brought in today we're going to be
talking about s collide the mad light
himself s Claude is one of my favorite
characters in anime and for me he was
the best anime character of 2019 that's
why I'm very excited to make this video
about him if you want to see more of
this kind of content make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you won't
know when future videos come out warning
there will be an amazing this video but
no manga spoilers now without further
ado let's jump into it when we are first
introduced to him in the anime ask a lot
is 33 years old and he's the leader of a
mercenary band of Vikings
floki the commander of the Jones Vikings
an organized and well disciplined
military unit of Vikings comes to speak
with him even though floki is a
commander of arguably the strongest unit
of Viking warriors and working directly
under the king he stands while
addressing ask allot who is sitting down
and resting his feet on the table if
we're looking at their body language
even though floki is supposed to be the
more powerful one ask a lad looks like
he's the one calling the shots clearly
this guy is set up as someone special
ask a lad doesn't give a [ __ ] and floki
goes with it
when floki finally sits down he's
leaning in while asked a lot is leaning
back on his chair usually the person
leaning in during social interactions is
the person who cares more the person of
quote-unquote lower status again even
though a squad is supposed to be of a
weaker rank he behaves as if he is of a
higher status than floki then loki tells
us glad that he wants him to kill Thor's
the troll of Jong Thor's is considered
to be the strongest bravest and most
well known warrior in the Viking world
as khalad goes on to smile and say that
he'll accept a job but he tells floki
that if he wants one of his former
Vikings dead it should be one of their
own who kills him
interestingly enough the leader of the
mercenary band of Vikings appears more
honorable here than the king's commander
who is working in the shadows to kill
one of his own a spear comes in during
the negotiation and asked lad is calm
while floki is caught off guard asked
alive uses this interruption to get the
terms and payment he wants and floki
agrees only late
is it shown that this fear wasn't an
accident and Bjorn threw it to purposely
kill one of Loki's men who was hiding
behind the tapestry on the wall floki
planned to catch ass clad off-guard and
gained the upper hand on him but ass
clad saw through it and got his own way
he maintained the upper hand throughout
the negotiation
so right away ass GLaDOS set up as an
interesting character he's calm cool and
collected in high-stakes situations
he's strategic and always a step or more
ahead of his opponent and he gets his
way he's not afraid of the king or the
strongest Viking in existence he's a
mercenary and says he's willing to do
anything for a payment but at the same
time he knows about honor and knows that
what floki and his professional military
unit are doing is disgraceful in short
it's difficult not to respect this guy
right off the bat ass glad goes on to do
the impossible he actually finds a way
to kill the superhuman thor's who is the
one punch man of Vikings although a
skcoll ad manages to get a hit on Thor's
and even break his sword
Thor's is just too strong and skilled
Thor's takes a squad sword and holds it
to his neck ass collide calm as a
cucumber says what's wrong kill me he's
ready to die and you can't help but
respect that because Thor's doesn't take
the opportunity to kill Aska lad Bjorn
captures Thor Finn and the tables turn
ask Allah takes advantage of this and
makes it seem like everything is going
according to his plan Thor's points out
that ass collide broke the rules of a
duel but as Gilad simply says and I
quote who cares and quote he's not after
honor he's after Thor's head he gives
the signal and the archers shoot the
legend Thor's even though ask a lad
cheated and killed our protagonist dad
he does keep his word when it comes to
redrawing his troops even when a young
man from Thor's group attacks Aska lad
he doesn't kill him he just punches him
and praises Thor's showing that he
respects the legend and probably feels
bad that he had to use such an honorable
means to win later when they're sailing
they find out that Thor Finn sneaked
aboard one of the ships his man suggests
throwing Thor fan overboard but a squad
says and I quote leave him he will die
soon anyway end quote
of course he doesn't die though and ask
lad keeps him close to himself
now we're giving plenty of reasons to
hate ask a lot he's a mercenary who will
break the rules for money he killed our
protagonist father who was a good and
virtuous man and so on there's no
shortage of reasons to dislike ask a lot
yet by the end of the first season I not
only don't dislike him he's one of my
favorite characters in anime and one of
the reasons for this is because he is
complex he does disgraceful things but
he has his own moral code and he often
doesn't do bad things even when he could
totally get away with it he's not
completely self-interested obviously if
you wanted to prioritize his own
survival then he would kill the kid
whose life mission is to kill him but he
doesn't granted he uses him for his own
purposes for a while but in the end you
could say he took him under his wing and
tried to teach him how to be a true
warrior over the course of 11 years
there were many times when another man
would have killed orphan but as khalad
wanted Thor's a son to outlive him up to
the last episode you could have
potentially made the argument that ask
lad did everything for selfish reasons
but this argument wouldn't hold after
episode 24 the King asks ask Allah to
make a decision he could save Wales the
country he loves or knut the king's
younger son one or the other
ask lad could keep his life and betray
canoes or climbed the ranks while
forgetting about Wales but in a
beautiful stroke of Ascalon signature
outside-of-the-box thinking ask lad
finds a way to save both it means
sacrificing his own life but he is
willing to do it he slices off the
king's head a moment that had me on the
edge of my seat like nothing else I
watched this year in and outside of
anime asked aloud acting like a madman
so that Knut could kill him and inherit
the throne
knowing that Knut wouldn't wage war
against Wales when Thor Fionn tries to
help him out of the situation asked lad
tells him to stay back he wants Knut to
kill him so that things go according to
plan but he also doesn't want the orphan
to die later he even offers to give his
life to Thor Fionn on the verge of death
he invites Thor Finn to finish him off
he tells Thornton to move forward and to
not stay stuck in a damn boring place
like this forever he tells him to go far
forward and to go beyond the world where
Thor's went he tells him to become a
true warrior
and then as Clyde dies he must have
killed many people in his life many of
who didn't deserve to die he had a lot
of problems to be sure
he was far from a saint however what's
interesting is the gray area he did do
bad things inexcusable things but he did
good things too he broke certain codes
of honor but he had his own code that he
followed he tried to help Knut Wales and
Thor Finn and was even willing to
sacrifice his own life to do it he
killed our protagonists virtuous father
in a disgraceful manner but he also
raised our protagonist and tried to
teach him how to be a true warrior in
his own way obviously there are many
aspects that were problematic in ask
alot that no one should try to emulate
but there were also respectable aspects
he was calm and maintained his composure
in the face of fear and even bravely
embraced death when his time came he
used his mind and strategized he always
tried to think ahead of his opponent and
outside of the box he had his own code
of principles and lived by them so that
even thoug racquel respected him and
kept him alive when he eventually caught
up with him Thor stood out in the series
as an especially good man but he was
also 39 years old when he died he wasn't
born being the virtuous man he was when
he died in fact he left the Vikings
because he had a problem with how he'd
been living he evolved and changed
similarly as khalad can be said to have
evolved and changed over the eleven
years between Thor's his death and his
own good characters like real-life
people are constantly changing and
evolving although he was no Thor's ask
Ladd died an honorable death in his own
right they both died for something
bigger than themselves
Thor's died to protect his son in
village and ask glad died to protect
Wales Knut and Thor fan to by dying as
khalad finally released Thor Fionn from
the mental hell of living only for
revenge at the expense of all other
things in the world of inland saga
almost all of the Vikings are messed up
but as cloud stood out because he was
wise brave disciplined and faithfully
followed his own sense of justice
sure compared to Saints ask lad would
look really bad but compared to the
majority of men around him who would
betray anyone and any belief to save
their own lives he looked pretty damn
admiral
and for all these reasons this
complicated badass will go down as my
favorite anime character of 2019 and
even as one of my favorite characters of
all time and that is it for today's
video
thank you so much for watching let me
know what you think of as glad as a
character and let me know who is your
favorite anime character of 2019 if you
enjoyed this video make sure to smash
that like button to let me know for more
videos like this one make sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell so you'll
actually get notified when future videos
come out let me know what other videos
you would like to see in the comments
below for more awesome anime content and
updates on new seasons make sure to
follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar you can now also find all
of our videos in podcast form on Spotify
and Apple music so definitely check that
out
link in the description a special thank
you goes out to our patrons on patreon
who help us survive YouTube issues and
who helped make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell dress fitted ala beat Anatole
cos ASCII alpha do angel Cruz and team
Sparky 65 and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans Steven
and Radha a Lola autumn Maddie Mac 239
makoto-kun the world Steelers Tyson
Kirino and the school bus thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]